je te défie de chanter le refrain sans
qui ces graves d'arras mais la chrono
choc tresses ils vous ont bien disparu
votre entreprise est fermé vous avez
fermé l'entreprise tout se fait par
ordinateur maintenant les gens ont une
vraie méfiance des machines
vous avez lu terminator mais le 2 + 3
vous étiez d'excellents vendeur mais
accepter le vous êtes des dinosaures il
s'est trouvé auquel on attribue gueule
par un vrai job mais un entretien pour
un stage qui pourrait mener à un job et
coutumes c'est peut-être notre toute
dernière chance jean marc dupraz il faut
que tu sois plus belle pour aller voir
il donne à voir gamins noirs il rejoint
oui on vous voit quand vous nous
entendez où je m'appelle billy tour vous
entends aussi très bien à super
5 % d'entre vous se verront offrir un
poste à plein temps et les 95 % restants
n'ont rien c'est comme une espèce de
hunger games mental contre une bande de
petits génies pour juste une fois le
boulot je suis live à des chefs d'equipe
pilotes me bat normalement sortir le
point sans prononcer le mot est tout à
fait suffisant à les vieux fist mois
mais le moi je crois que ça va vraiment
pas le faire vous êtes d'alger ouais
j'hallucine fois tu faire vous êtes
vieux jeu vous prenait pour des mecs
important parfois pari risqué pour
rapporter un max votre premier défi
créer une application des idées les gens
prennent des photos constamment alors ce
serait bien qu'on puisse prendre des
photos et les mettre sur la ligne sur la
ligne pour les partager avec nos potes
ça c'est in-stat g le mieux serait plus
un partage social sur la ligne 2
secondes quand tu dis sur la ligne tu
veux dire en ligne ouais
voici nos baies clarac et rouge signifie
non et la raquette verte signifie oui
boire une bière avec son patron si vous
voulez vous acheter une avec moi vous
m'en parler non je n'irai pas mon jeté
une avec vous la peta votre mission
trouver le blog pourquoi vous n'iriez
pas trouvé le programmeur tout de suite
il s'appelle charles xavier il est
professeur à stanford
il est en fauteuil roulant au cayston
fauteuil way charles xavier
c'est très amusant professeur xavier on
sait que c'est vous m'avez démasqué
cyclope malicia bon lecteur aussi sic je
voudrais partager un peu de ma sagesse à
des professeurs